[Music]
that's right you guys guessed it
this Halloween build is going to be
Ash's chainsaw hand from the Evil Dead
films
you
now as I said you guys had a lot of
great suggestions and I will get to most
of them but we had several people
request this and to be honest it's one
of my favorite film franchises and I've
never built one before so rather than
build one completely from scratch which
there are a lot of great tutorials out
there on how to build it using things
like like an old gas can and some
plywood or even like like a tied bottle
or some kind of detergent bottle or
something and converting that into one I
want mine to kind of work and because
it's Halloween there are tons of
Halloween stores and party stores that
have these fake chainsaws and there are
all kinds of coupons and stuff like that
out there so you can get them pretty
cheap so this one I actually with the
coupon I got at a party store for about
26 bucks and what's cool about it
there's got a working cane
so what I'm gonna have to do is take it
apart and see how I can get a fist in
there without moving too many components
around so that it still works I want to
still have the sound effect but I got
people take this handle off and move the
switch to the inside so that I can
operate it within definitely gonna have
to do some modifications to make it look
a little bit more like Ash's his kind of
swoops down yeah I'm going to cut some
of this out add a piece of sheet metal
we're going to have to build the metal
handle and cut this one down take this
one off and remove this bogus pull cord
knob thing here yeah the other side the
other side's pretty good
I mean rebus we're going to paint it up
dirty it up but for the most part we've
got a decent amount of work to do to it
all right so some of the other items
that we're going to be using this is a
scrap piece of sheet metal this wooden
dowel some aluminum flat bar this 3-inch
pipe coupling some various corner
brackets this little toggle switch it's
a various nuts and bolts and screws and
so far it's about it this is what I'm
going with I hope you guys dig it kind
of dive right in and see what this
sucker looks like inside
alright so we just open that sucker up
here you can see there's quite a bit of
room inside there so be easy to fit a
hand and removing the switch out of the
handle was a piece of cake it's a ain't
no pop right off switch was still intact
[Music]
so I took my pipe coupling and bridge
the back and trace it out with my
sharpie so that I knew where to make my
cuts
also the same thing on the top where I
was going to cut it down to kind of give
it that reduced look that matches a
little bit more to ashes chainsaw so
using my plastic cutting bit on my
rotary tool I had cut it out
pull that thing up then I went back over
it once right finished cutting these out
with my sanding bit kind of get rid of
some of those rough edges but hand fits
you know while I'm at it I'm just going
to cut off the pull chain knob because
we're going to place that with our own
[Music]
so I cut the bar down because ashes only
has is like on the side this is cut down
because we're going to put a handle on
the top so once I cut out the top piece
and it's got that kind of reduced look
now I'm going to cut piece of dowel it's
going to be the inside of my handle and
then I made some lines down the center
of another piece of dowel and I'm going
to cut it down the middle and that's
going to be the top and bottom grip on
the top handle that we're going to cut
and Bend out of our flat bar and that's
going to go across the top of the castle
so I made some holes in the handles and
then my flat bar I just put in the vise
and bent into the shape that I wanted
and that looks pretty good
kind of deciding how much I want to come
down I'm going to cut a piece off
I'm going to need some of that flat bar
to attach the inside handle that we have
something to grip inside of the chainsaw
so now I'm just cutting off my flat bar
looking pretty good I got my sheet metal
and was thin enough sheet melt where
actually I could cut it with a pair of
hobby shears which made it a little bit
easier to cut now I've got my little
brackets and I'm measuring where to make
my holes on the chainsaw and the
coupling the brackets themselves I had
to bend quite a bit to kind of fit the
contours of the chainsaw I also use some
aluminum strap
because it's a little easier to work
with easier to bend
once I made my measurements my holes and
drill them out with my drill on the
coupling
and then I attach my brackets just a
screw a nut and a lock washer in there
so sitting back out
screwie and snug
and make sure that everything is lining
up still fold I attach everything
now I'm cutting another piece of dowel
it's going to be my pull chain sanding
it down drill the hole through the
middle and using a piece of growth that
head line around the shop feed it
through the hole hole chain another
piece of dowel I screwed to that piece
of room and flat bar we had scrap and
that's going to attach the inside of my
chainsaw so I have something to grab
onto and you can attach the switch to
the inside
once I have the handle secured fit
pretty good
shut it scoop to the bottom into the
dowel hold it in place along with the
bracket
[Music]
and the excess wiring in there that I
didn't need I removed
there was actually a switch already in
there that wasn't attached to anything
so I just removed that all the other
wiring I taped using electrical tape
kind of get out of the way and the
switch I use electrical tape to attach
the switch to the handle now the piece
of plastic that I cut off the top is
sanded the edges down so it still had
that reduced look and then i reeked lewd
the top part to the chainsaw that was a
hot glue
until the whole to my piece of sheet
metal right to put my toggle switch and
then I put the sheet metal in place
using some screws
just like
I use various Hardware kind of give it a
look like it would build a lot of scrap
pieces
once everything is secured attach my
pipe coupling I had to feed the screws
in from the inside so that the screws
weren't digging into my wrists also
that's the look that the original one
has so
[Music]
once I got everything into place and
tighten everything down
make sure it was secure I taped
everything off that I didn't want
painted
I painted using krylon I used a red
gloss at first over the whole body of it
and then went back over it with a flat
darker red kind of give it that worn
look
need an oil and gas cap so a couple of
water bottle cap suffice
using some black latex paint egg liner
on the shaft wanted it down and paint it
over all of the crevices and cracks
[Music]
once I painted in those cracks that one
right over it with the paper towel
to remove any excess this leaves a
really good dingy grungy kind of look to
it like it's covered in oil and dirt and
stains gives it a nice weathered look
and it's usually the paint job that
sells any problem
[Music]
Spray the chainsaw blade with a nickel
finish and then the same thing with the
wash the black paint paint in all the
cracks crevices immediately wiped it off
to give it that kind of dingy gray look
groovy alright well there it is
Ash's chainsaw hand from the Evil Dead
movies overall I have to say I'm pretty
happy with the way it turned out it was
a little more involved and I actually
originally thought it was going to be
but a few things that maybe you guys
didn't notice when I was building
I needed some gas in an oil cap for the
top kind of forgot about it but
fortunately I drank a couple bottles of
water while I was working so I just
painted the bottle caps and glued them
to the top here the pull cord it's kind
of loose I think it looks kind of neat
when it's kind of dangling you could
just glue it right to the actual
chainsaw I like the way it kind of hangs
a little bit with the rope just kind of
attached inside there I hope you guys
enjoyed watching this build as much as I
enjoy building it it was a lot of fun
and gave me a great excuse to build one
that's what's something I've always
kinda wanted to do I have never gotten
around to so this gave me a great excuse
so thanks guys for the suggestions and
yeah until next time keep watching keep
building enjoy your Halloween don't
forget to look me up on Facebook at
James Jim J Roz and yeah thanks again
for watching guys you guys are awesome
see you next time
[Music]
you